President Joe Biden is selling a
rebranded economic program the White
House is calling phynomics I didn't come
up with the name
I really did bidenomics is about
building an economy from the middle out
and the bottom up not the top town in
what the White House calls a major
economic address is the presidential
campaign heats up the president made
Chicago his first stop on a tour to
promote his economic program
the tour aides say is an attempt to
promote his trillion dollar
infrastructure law passed in 2021 that
added more money for roads Bridges and
schools this week the White House also
announced a plan to expand internet
access for Rural communities on the
president's bidenomics tour he's touting
near historic low unemployment slowing
inflation and the massive bipartisan
infrastructure building pushed through
Congress but the term bidenomics could
go from positive to pejorative if the
economy heads South
the presidential election is more than a
year away but some analysts say
rebranding Biden's economic program or
the phrase that borrows from President
Ronald Reagan's popular Reaganomics in
the 1980s might be too little too late
to help him here we are two years into
this Administration and we get this
nebulous term and I think many people
are going to it's not going to move the
needle any way shape or form but again
because of this administration's track
record it's highly unlikely that we're
going to see them actually identify it
polls show the majority of Americans are
unhappy with Biden's handling of the
economy coupled with a tightening race
between Biden and his likely Republican
rival in 2024 former president Donald
Trump Dynamics is about the future
saying restore the American dream
whether bidenomics can give the current
president an edge will be tested in the
administration's new campaign to promote
it may God protect our troops John
hendren Al Jazeera Chicago